Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
No siempre fui tan grandote
como me ven ahora.
Alguna vez fui más chiquito;
cuando era más chiquito,
más o menos de este tamaño,
tenía miedos, por supuesto.
Bueno, ahora también,
pero en esa época tenía miedos distintos
de los que tengo ahora.
Y tenía un miedo bastante particular,
que es que me daba miedo
quedarme dormido.
Porque cuando uno duerme
la consciencia desaparece.
Y a mí esa desaparición me hacía sospechar
que la consciencia podía ser algo frágil.
¿Quién te garantiza
que cuando te vas a dormir
te vas a despertar a la mañana siguiente,
que tu consciencia va a volver?
Yo me hacía esas preguntas y obviamente
después terminaba haciendo cosas
como caminar descalzo
por mi casa toda la noche,
con tal de no quedarme dormido.
Hoy, muchos años después,
yo soy científico,
más precisamente
soy un neurocientífico grandote,
y mi trabajo es entender
cómo el cerebro genera la consciencia.
Y, ¿qué es la consciencia?
Bueno, a veces las cosas
que nos son más inmediatas
son las más difíciles de entender.
Y no hay nada más inmediato
que nuestra propia consciencia.
Pero una analogía que ayuda
a pensar la consciencia
es imaginarnos sentados en un teatro
y en ese teatro se representa la obra
más compleja y más real que existe,
la obra que contiene
todas las imágenes que vemos,
todos los sonidos que escuchamos,
todas las emociones que sentimos.
Lo que vemos en esa obra es lo que vemos,
lo que escuchamos en esa obra
es lo que escuchamos,
y lo que sentimos en esa obra,
lo que nos hace sentir,
es lo que sentimos.
Y lo que se representa en la obra son
los contenidos de nuestra consciencia.
Y la obra es la consciencia misma.
Cuando se apagan las luces
que iluminan el escenario
donde se representa la obra,
la consciencia también se apaga.
La consciencia desaparece.
Pero por suerte, por supuesto,
cuando se vuelven a encender las luces
que iluminan el escenario,
la consciencia se vuelve a encender,
la consciencia vuelve a aparecer.
En mi trabajo usé distintas
herramientas para entender
qué pasa en el cerebro cuando
la consciencia desaparece.
Una de esas herramientas
es, justamente,
eso que me daba miedo cuando
era chico: el sueño profundo.
Pero también investigué personas
bajo anestesia general
o pacientes en un estado de coma,
que son todas condiciones en las cuales
las luces que iluminan la obra,
la consciencia, se apagan.
Y el escenario donde
se representa esa obra
que contiene todo lo que sentimos
está, por supuesto, dentro del cerebro,
está en un conjunto de regiones
que se llaman red frontal parietal.
Se llaman así porque está
más o menos dentro del cráneo,
por encima de los ojos, frontal,
y por encima las orejas,
por el costado, parietal.
Nosotros somos conscientes de algo
únicamente en la medida en que
la información sobre ese algo
accede a las neuronas
de la red frontal parietal,
y desde ahí puede acceder
a todo el cerebro.
Explota y accede a todo el cerebro.
En condiciones como el sueño profundo
o condiciones como la anestesia o el coma,
la red frontal parietal se apaga,
como se apagan las luces
que iluminan el escenario
donde se representa esa obra.
Entonces, pensando en estas cosas,
hace algunos años
me empecé a hacer una pregunta
que iba a cambiar mi carrera,
pero sobre todo iba a cambiar
mi manera de entender el mundo
y de entenderme a mí mismo.
Y la pregunta es la siguiente:
¿qué pasa si la red frontal parietal
no solamente no se apaga,
sino que se enciende con una actividad
todavía mayor a la normal,
con una actividad todavía mayor
a la que tenemos todos nosotros
acá y ahora, por ejemplo,
conscientes y despiertos?
¿Qué pasa si ocurre
lo opuesto a lo que pasa
cuando nos quedamos dormidos
en la inconsciencia?
En toda obra de teatro
pasan un montón de cosas,
y en realidad uno
no las ve en el escenario.
Es lo que pasa tras bambalinas.
Todo el trabajo para la puesta en escena,
y cuando uno va al teatro,
aún con las luces que iluminan
el escenario encendidas,
uno nunca ve esas cosas.
Pero están ahí.
Entonces, la pregunta que
yo me había hecho es la siguiente:
¿qué pasa si no solamente no apagamos
las luces que iluminan el escenario,
sino que las encendemos con una
intensidad tan, pero tan grande,
que hasta la puesta en escena,
hasta todo lo que ocurre tras bambalinas,
no solo se vuelve visible,
sino que se vuelve hasta
imposible de no ver?
Claramente, herramientas como
el sueño profundo o la anestesia,
que apagan las luces de la consciencia,
no me iban a servir
para responder esta pregunta.
Yo necesitaba un herramienta diferente,
una herramienta específica
para manifestar con más intensidad
todas esas cosas que ocurren
en el cerebro, en la mente,
incluso las que están ahí ocultas,
tras bambalinas.
La herramienta que yo necesitaba
era un manifestador de mentes.
Y un manifestador de mentes
no suena a la clase de herramienta
que uno va y compra
en una ferretería cualquiera,
pero yo me enteré que existen,
y son tan reales como
el sueño profundo o la anestesia.
Solo que si nunca escucharon hablar
de los manifestadores de mentes
es porque el nombre que tienen,
en realidad, está en griego.
Se llaman "psicodélicos".
En griego "psico" significa "mente"
y "delos", manifestar.
Manifestadores de mentes.
Los psicodélicos son moléculas.
Y algunas son naturales
y están en cactus, como la mescalina,
o en hongos, como la psilocibina,
y otras son sintéticas, hechas
por el hombre, como el LSD.
Y generan cambios muy intensos
en nuestra percepción del mundo,
en nuestras emociones,
pero también en nuestra percepción
de nosotros mismos
y, sobre todo, de la relación que
tenemos con todo lo que nos rodea.
Y son cambios que se generan interfiriendo
en las conversaciones químicas
que entablan las neuronas del
cerebro para comunicarse entre sí.
Y en nuestras investigaciones
aprendimos, de hecho,
que estas neuronas están principalmente
en la red frontal parietal del cerebro.
Y los psicodélicos
encienden exageradamente
la actividad de la red
frontal parietal del cerebro.
Podríamos decir que hacen, de hecho,
lo opuesto al sueño profundo
o a la anestesia,
o lo que vemos en un estado de coma.
Actualmente, con mi laboratorio
de la Universidad Buenos Aires,
estamos realizando el primer estudio
sobre los efectos de un psicodélico
natural en la historia argentina.
Y nos interesa estudiar
qué ocurre en el cerebro humano
cuando eso pasa, pero también
qué es lo que le ocurre la persona.
Qué es lo que la persona siente.
Y uno de nuestros sujetos experimentales
expresó eso quizás mucho mejor
de lo que yo lo podría expresar.
Sentado todavía con un montón de cables
y electrodos pegados a su cabeza,
que son los que usamos justamente
para medir la actividad su cerebro,
nos miró y nos dijo
que su experiencia visual
fue tan abrumadora, tan intensa,
que sintió que tuvo que
abrir los ojos para dejar de ver.
Abrir los ojos para dejar de ver.
Los psicodélicos también
se están investigando como medicinas,
como terapia para ayudar
a pacientes con depresión
o con la ansiedad que puede
generar algo tan terrible
como un diagnóstico de cáncer.
Y los resultados hasta ahora
son muy positivos.
La evidencia nos dice que los pacientes
que más se benefician
de los psicodélicos como terapias
son los que sienten
que desaparece esa frontera
que separa su propio cuerpo, y a ellos
mismos, de todas las demás cosas.
Se sienten en todas las cosas.
Ellos ya no están sentados
en una butaca viendo la obra,
sino que las luces también los iluminan
y entienden entonces que
ellos y nosotros también
en realidad están, y estamos,
dentro de la obra misma.
Pero la misma experiencia,
sobre todo sin supervisión adecuada,
puede generar un estado
de mucha ansiedad y de angustia.
Lo cual no es extraño si entendemos
que una medicina se receta
para alguien que la necesita.
Y consumirla o suministrarla
fuera de este contexto sí es ilegal,
pero sobre todo es irresponsable.
Necesitamos responsabilidad.
Porque dije que estamos realizando
el primer estudio de historia
del país con psicodélicos,
pero estamos en el año 2019.
Entonces, si realmente me creen,
que son herramientas tan útiles,
¿por qué nadie las investigó antes?
Bueno, en realidad, en los años
50 y 60 en Estados Unidos,
los psicodélicos se investigaron
muy intensamente,
pero en un momento pasó algo
que no tendría que haber pasado.
Los psicodélicos salieron de los
laboratorios, salieron de los hospitales
y fueron consumidos masivamente
y de formas inapropiadas
y, lógicamente, se prohibieron.
Y por eso es que hoy
es extremadamente difícil
hacer investigación científica
con psicodélicos.
Esta situación tiene que cambiar.
¡Déjennos hacer investigación
científica con psicodélicos!
Esto no se trata de consumo,
se trata de conocimiento,
se trata de ciencia
y se trata de medicina.
(Aplausos)
Entendemos que hay una
responsabilidad asociada a eso,
que no es automático.
En los próximos 10 años, si esto pasa,
vamos a poder beneficiarnos enormemente
de los psicodélicos como herramienta
para entender la mente,
como medicina para ayudar
a quienes realmente lo necesitan.
Pero que eso pase en los próximos 10 años
depende de no repetir
todos esos errores del pasado.
Depende, esencialmente,
de que esta vez sea diferente.
Yo personalmente,
hoy ya me siento diferente,
porque a mí estas preguntas,
estas nuevas posibilidades
me apasionan tanto,
que yo sueño con estas cosas.
Entonces, hoy yo
me voy a dormir a la noche,
tan pero tan entusiasmado,
que es por eso que ya ni siquiera
se me ocurre pensar
si me voy a despertar o no
a la mañana siguiente.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)